assister à la victoire de l'équipe de
france face au pérou alors que l'on est
censé se trouver derrière son bureau une
réalité chez le groupe sodexo basé à
guyancourt l'opérateur de restauration
et de services accueille 900 salariés
ce mondial 2018 est un moyen de
rassembler encore plus son personnel
l'organisation en tout cas de des matchs
en tout cas de la diffusion des matchs
pour la coupe du monde ça rentre
pleinement dans le cadre de parole à ce
qu'on a envie d'offrir à nos
collaborateurs sur site pour pour leur
qualité de vie en plus de la
retransmission des matches des bleus sur
écran géant la salle de restauration a
été décorée aux couleurs du drapeau
tricolore
une urne a été mise à disposition pour
que chacun puisse parier avant le
lancement du match un moment que
n'aurait pas manqué martin laetitia et
sylvie super puis ça permet de se
retrouver sur un moment convivial donc
c'est vrai pour ça génial ça nous permet
de l'équipe allait devoir nous voir jean
notre cadre de vie plus agréable et puis
célèbre du monde peut en tout cas la
france présente enfin c'est tout ce qui
pose une plage de travail assez flexible
donc
c'est vrai que vu leur c'était quand
même facile à s'organiser selon une
étude menée par le site internet bureaux
locaux en france 36 % des entreprises
ont décidé de diffuser certains matchs
dans les espaces communs 19 % des
entreprises autorisent leurs salariés
regarder les matchs discrètement
al'inverse un quart des entreprises ont
décidé d'interdire à leurs salariés de
regarder les matchs au bureau de toute
façon tout le monde a envie de regarder
le match ça arrive une fois tous les
quatre ans et c'est plutôt un événement
qui est très fédérateur qui est
conviviale donc enfin voilà on s'est dit
autant leur organiser de manière
officielle pour pour faut pour tout le
monde et pour que les gens voient là
puissent le voir en toute tranquillité
les salariés de sodexo vont encore avoir
de nouvelles occasions de partager ces
moments de convivialité puisque les
hommes de didier deschamps sont
qualifiés pour les huitièmes de finale